what I want to do in this video is a
calculus proof of the famous centripetal
acceleration formula that tells us the
magnitude of centripetal acceleration
the actual direction will change it's
always going to be pointing inwards but
the magnitude of centripetal
acceleration is equal to the magnitude
of the velocity squared divided by the
radius I want to be very clear this is a
scalar formula right over here it's
talking about the magnitude of the
acceleration and the magnitude of the
velocity if these were vectors we would
have arrows drawn over so this really I
don't want people to get confused
because this is a V this is really
referring to the speed squared and this
is the magnitude so these are all these
are all scalar quantities so to do that
let's imagine some object maybe it's
some object in orbit around a planet or
something so let's say that that's the
planet and that you have some object
that is in orbit around the planet and
it is going in a counterclockwise
direction and so let's specify its
position vector as a function of time so
let's specify its position functor as a
function of time so that is its position
vector and it's going to change as a
function of time as this thing spins
around and what we're going to assume
for the purposes of this for the
purposes of this proof I guess you can
call it let me draw some axes over here
let me draw some axes so if that is our
Y axis and this is our x axis we're
going to define theta to be the angle
the angle between the positive x axis
and our vector so that is going to be
theta and we're going to assume that
this thing is in an orbit with a radius
of R so the magnitude of our position
vector even though the direction is
going to change the magnitude of our
position vector is not going to change
it's always going to have length R so
this is going in a circle of radius R so
I can write it here the magnitude of our
position vector which is changing as a
function of time is going to be R so how
can we write how can we actually express
the position vector in terms of its
components at any given time well we can
write the position vector and I'll do it
an engineering notation and so you might
want to review those videos if some of
this looks for and I will do a little
bit of basic trigonometry and breaking
down the vector
to its components and I encourage you to
review those videos if some of that
looks a little bit daunting if you take
the position vector at any time so if
you take the position vector at any time
the magnitude is R this angle is Theta
right over here it's X component under
the X component in blue it's X component
this vector right over here is going to
be the magnitude of its X component I
should say is going to be R cosine of
theta we've learned that this comes from
basic trigonometry when we started
actually we start I think a
two-dimensional projectile motion we saw
how to break these vectors down into its
components and the y component of this
vector the y component of this vector is
going to be our sine of theta it's going
to be the same thing as this vector the
magnitude right over there so this is
going to be our sine sine of theta so
the position vector at any time so the
position vector at any time can be
written as the sum of its x and y
components so it's the magnitude of its
X component is going to be R cosine of
theta and I could write theta as a
function of time if I like but I'm just
going to write R cosine of actually let
me write it that way so that shows that
theta is going to be a function of time
this thing is moving and there's going
to be that times the I unit vector we're
going to do engineering notation right
over here so that is the I unit vector
this tells us that that is the X
component it's going in the positive x
Direction plus plus the magnitude of the
Y component which is our sine of theta
which is going to be a function of time
so I'm going to be clear the function of
time the function of time applies to the
theta put some parentheses around it
like that and that is going in the J
direction that is going in the J
direction so that is our J unit vector
so that is going in the J direction so
now we have position as a function of
theta which is actually a function of
time so let's take the derivative of
this thing right over here so what is so
what is d the derivative of our position
vector the derivative of our position
vector with respect to time
well that's just going to be our
velocity vector so that's just going to
be our velocity vector as a function of
time and it's going to be equal to we
just have to take the derivative of each
of these to H of these parts with
respect to time and you just do the
chain rule so you're going to have the R
sit outside that's just a constant so
you're going to have are the derivative
of cosine of theta T with respect to
theta T so I'm just doing the chain rule
right over here that's going to be
negative sine of theta T theta T and
then it's the chain rule we also have to
multiply that times the derivative of
theta T I'm sorry the derivative of
theta of T with respect to T so times D
theta DT this is just the chain rule
right over here and so that's going to
be how it's changing in the X direction
and in the Y direction we do something
very similar in the Y direction we take
the same derivative you have the our
scalar out front our and then the
derivative of sine of theta with respect
to theta is going to be cosine of theta
and I'll write it as a function of time
and then do the chain rule you also have
to multiply that times the rate at which
data is changing with respect to T times
D theta DT and this is going all going
to be times our J this is all times our
J unit vector now there's something that
you might already realize and you should
re-watch the video on angular velocity
if this is foreign to you but D theta DT
this is our angular velocity that's why
I said to rewatch that video this right
over here the rate at which the angle
changes with respect to time that is
angular velocity so this right over here
is that right over there is angular
velocity and for the sake of this video
and this is an assumption that we'll
have to make for this for this formula
right over here we're going to assume
that Omega which is the trait of change
of our angle with respect to time we're
going to assume that that is we're going
to assume that this is constant so this
is an assumption that we're making for
this proof this is we are going to
assume that Omega is constant
and if Omega is constant that we can
treat it literally as a constant and we
can actually factor it out of this
expression so let's actually factor out
a negative Omega R from this expression
right over here so we can rewrite our
velocity as a function of time is equal
to I'm going to factor out a negative
Omega times R and if you factor out a
negative Omega R what you're left with
put some big brackets right over here is
this first term the negative got
factored out the R got factored out the
Omega got factored out you just have a
sine of theta T here sine of theta of T
so let me an ident even after I didn't
have to make it explicit that theta is a
function of T but this makes it explicit
that theta is a function of T theta is a
function of T and then times our I unit
vector times a unit vector plus plus so
if we're factoring out a negative a
negative Omega R this becomes negative
cosine cosine of theta which is a
function of T theta which is a function
of T and that that's times our J unit
vector times our J unit vector and let
me close the parentheses in the right
way so we factored out negative Omega R
now let's take the derivative of this
with respect to time so if we take if we
take and let me give myself some real
estate if we take the derivative of the
velocity with respect to time this is
clearly just what the acceleration is as
a function of time and we're going to
assume that the magnitude of this thing
is constant but the actual direction is
changing so this is the acceleration as
a function of time is going to be equal
to is going to be equal to let me get my
colors right it's going to be equal to
we have this negative Omega R open from
the parentheses so what's the derivative
of this thing right over here so the
derivative of sine with respect to theta
we're just doing the chain rule here
derivative of sine with respect to theta
is going to be cosine of theta so we get
cosine of theta cosine of theta as a
function of T and then chain rule we
also have to take multiply that times
the derivative of theta
with respect to T and the derivative of
theta with respect to T I could write D
theta DT or I could write D theta DT
here but that's once again is just
another that is just Omega so that is
just Omega and that's of course in the I
direction and then from that we and then
next to that we're going to have to take
the derivative cosine of theta of T with
respect to theta so that's going to be
that would be negative sine of theta but
we have a negative out front so it
becomes positive sine positive sine of
theta as a function of T and then we
have to do the chain rule the derivative
of theta with respect to T we have to
multiply by this and that we could write
d theta DT right here but that once
again is the same thing the same thing
as Omega and all of that two being
multiplied times the J the J unit vector
and then we can close our parentheses so
now let's factor out this other Omega
and we get something interesting we get
the acceleration our acceleration vector
as a function of time is equal to if we
factor out another Omega we get negative
Omega negative Omega squared R I'm just
factoring out another Omega so that
becomes negative Omega squared R times
and I'll write it in parentheses here x
times cosine of theta cosine of theta as
a function of T times our I unit vector
the color changing is the hard part here
plus plus B the same color plus sine of
theta which is a function of T times our
J unit vector times our J unit vector
now what is what is our what is this all
of this business right over here what is
all of this business if you just look at
this part right over there
well R times this especially if you
distributed the R that's exactly this
thing right over here in fact if you
distribute the AR you get exactly R
cosine of theta as a function of T times
our unit vector plus R sine theta as a
function of T times the J unit vector so
everything that I squared off in orange
right over here
this is our position vector this is our
position vector as a function of time so
all of that work we did we just got a
very interesting result we got that our
acceleration vector as a function of
time is equal to the negative of our
constant angular velocity squared or I
should say really the magnitude of our
angular velocity which we're assuming is
a constant the negative of that squared
times our position vector and just to be
clear angular velocity is kind of the
pseudo vector it tends to be treated
like a scalar especially when you're
dealing in two-dimensional and in two
dimensions like this it's actually
formally a pseudo scalar but let's just
go with this right here we're assuming
that this right over here is a constant
scalar quantity now how do we now what
we want to do is we want to relate this
we want to relate this essentially the
scalar version of it so if we want to
take the magnitude of both sides so
let's take the magnitude so that we're
saying the acceleration vector is equal
to this constant times times the
position vector so let's take the
magnitude of both sides of this thing
the magnitude of both sides the
magnitude of both sides of this thing so
then we get the magnitude of the
acceleration vector which I'm just going
to call a sub C is going to be equal to
so you could say the magnitude of this
negative Omega squared well when you
take the magnitude that's like taking
the absolute value in fact the absolute
value is the one dimensional version of
magnitude that's just going to be a
positive Omega squared we just care we
don't care about the direction sine
gives us direction we just care about
the actual size so this is going to be
this is going to be Omega squared let me
be clear this is equal to the magnitude
of negative Omega squared times the
magnitude of our position vector times
the magnitude of our position vector the
magnitude of Omega squared is just going
to be Omega squared you can get rid of
the sign and the magnitude of our
position vector we saw at the beginning
of this video is just R it's just our
radius is just our radius so this right
over here is just going to be equal to
the radius of the circle that we are
going around
now we also know that angular velocity
or if we want to be particularly the
magnitude of angular velocity is equal
to the magnitude of our velocity or
another way to think about it is the
speed of our object divided by the
radius of the circle that it is going
around so we can substitute that right
over here so if we square it so this is
going to be V over R squared and we saw
that in the video on angular velocity
times R and this is all going to be the
magnitude of our acceleration which is
really our centripetal acceleration our
inward directed acceleration and so this
is going to be equal to and I think you
see where this is going this is equal to
V squared over R squared times R this R
cancels out with with the R squared so
you're just left with V squared over R
and you're done
the magnitude of the centripetal
acceleration is equal to your speed the
magnitude of your velocity squared
divided by your radius and we are done